all of this is governed by these
mathematical rules which are very much
like what you would experience if we
were actually inside of a video game
first self-aware entities appeared yeah
that's in a sense of universe waking up
and becoming aware of itself right is
actually as an opportunity if we can
figure out what's going on with black
holes and they may even get some clues
by looking at them then that can
actually maybe be the master key that
can help us unlock some of the deepest
mysteries of quantum gravity yes
yeah the unified theory of physics snap
decision you know should we ask this
person on a date or not where it might
come down to just whether one neuron
fired or not in the beginning triggering
a whole cascade of events could end up
with you living in this city you know be
married to this person with children or
be living somewhere completely different
doing something different I'm quite
optimistic that we can create the really
inspiring future with technology but
that's gonna require winning what I call
the wisdom race the race between the
growing power of the technology
exponentially growing power of the
technology with the wisdom with which
you manage this tech but there's a catch
here technology is getting exponentially
more and more powerful
all right and at some point it crosses
the threshold of power we're learning
from mistakes actually goes from being
good strategy to being a really really
bad strategy and I feel we've already
crossed that threshold with nuclear
weapons and we've on the verge of
crossing the threshold with synthetic
biology which can be used fantastically
to improve our health or to create
engineered pandemics and we're totally
gonna cross that threshold with
artificial intelligence if we succeed in
building artificial general intelligence
that can outsmart us you know in all
ways it's not difficult at all
to make the world much much better it's
just that we have our monkey brains and
and most political leaders are very
clueless about technology and in short
it was go into careers with machines
socket and are going to continue to be
bad at four
longtime boom what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Island sake
on we are on site in Boston we have the
absolute pleasure to be sitting down
with Swedish American cosmologists
physicist professor at MIT the author of
our mathematical universe life 3.0 the
founder of the future of life Institute
dr. max tegmark hello it's a pleasure
thank you for coming on to our show it's
such an honor to be talking to you
pleasure is mine huge mentor to so many
people that are trying to figure out
where we're going in our future as an
entire society and civilization so super
honored and really excited to talk to
you about everything okay there is quite
a bit of content already on the internet
about a lot of the things that you talk
about you have you know your books on
the internet your TED Talks are on the
internet your talk set previously where
you've talked about some of the these
higher level subjects I want to really
get into what we can say is not
available on the internet yet and so
let's see if we can start off by talking
about the the most kind of high level
understanding of the mathematical
universe because and let's see if I can
preface by by saying this you've said
that all of the mathematical constants
and equations can fit on a t-shirt and
that speaks very highly of how we can
potentially have a lens to see the world
through in a codified way through math
and that could potentially be a way of
even understanding how it can work
computationally all the way from a cell
or an atom all the way up to how a
society works so and how planets orbit
etc so speak to us about this at a high
level and tell us about it
so I think the single most striking
thing I've learned so far in my career
as a scientist is that the ultimate
nature of reality whatever it is is just
much weirder than we thought much more
different from what we thought it was
then people in their wildest dreams
would have imagined in the past no we
used to think well there's this stuff
you know it moves in certain ways and
certain properties and like this is
solid this is a bit squishy is red you
know and and gradually I think we've
come to the conclusion that all of this
is governed by these mathematical rules
which are very much like what you would
experience if we were actually inside of
a video game yeah you know if you were
pac-man or something and started to
study your pac-man world you discover
not only is stuff moving around it has
certain properties but the things that
you first thought had some sort of a
philosophical physical nature are all
behaving according to simple
mathematical rules you'd be basically
rediscovering the source code that the
programmer had put in there yes right
and that first sounds kind of nutty when
you say it and then in my mathematical
or mathematical universe the book I even
go as far as saying our universe isn't
just described by math it is
mathematical in the sense of being a
mathematical structure by which I mean
that our universe doesn't just have some
mathematical properties it has only
mathematical properties yes much like a
computer game that sounds very nutty so
let's break it down a little bit like if
you take an object like this book for
example well it seems like it has a lot
of very non mathematical properties it's
bend the ball and has a paper smell and
different colors so those don't seem
like mathematical properties at all
right
my mom and many with her think your math
basically as a sadistic form of torture
the schoolteachers have invented that to
make us feel bad about ourselves or
maybe as a bag of tricks for
manipulating numbers but like what
properties of this book are numbers well
there's a three here but that tells us
nothing about the nature of reality it's
just I decided to put it there right but
if you look more closely what you
actually have here it seen through my
physics eyes is a big blob of electrons
and quarks and what properties does an
electron have -1 1/2 1 and so on and
even though we physicists have given
these properties nerdy names like the
electric charge the spin and they look
the lepton number they're just numbers
right the only difference between an
electron and a quark as far as we can
tell are what those corresponding
numbers are and in fact all the
particles that make us everything in the
world here are described by the
different sets of these these numbers
and space itself that all of this stuff
is in you know what properties this
space have 3 as a property of space
that's the largest number of fingers I
can hold that are all perpendicular to
each other again you know we came up
with a nerdy name for this the
dimensionality of space but it's a
number and Einstein discovered some more
properties of space called curvature and
topology which are also things
mathematicians study and if ultimately
everything in space as well as space
itself has only mathematical properties
then it starts to sound a little bit
less than saying that yes actually we
own this living in this gigantic
mathematical object yes
it's and it's very interesting to break
it down from the ok earth 93 million
miles from star and it orbits in this
ellipse 365.25 days per orbit and then
there's the breakdown of how a cell can
be
seen mathematically there's a breakdown
of how an atom and the electron and the
proton can be seen mathematically like
you're just describing so everything can
be described then mathematically
potentially and then it can get us to
potentially the code of what is our
universe and then that can give us a
huge jumpstart into a better rapper
Taric Terr potentially and how we are
playing and how we need to understand
the code of where we live right and I
think a lot of people have a hard time
letting go of this idea that mathematics
is just ultimately describing some
relationships between stuff that's
fundamentally non-mathematical if you're
in a computer game there is no actual
stuff in pac-man right it's the entire
nature of pac-woman or these little
things you gobble up or the monsters or
just relationships between abstract
things that have no intrinsic properties
at all there's you know no actual stuff
there and in the same way I think this
is what we've learned about a physical
world it's the relationships that really
really matter between things in the
world and yes that's ultimately all
there is the entities themselves have no
properties except the relationships that
they have that's not that different in
some sense from our thoughts and the
subjective experiences they feel a
little bit more ethereal you know than a
book or an apple but it's the
relationship between the different
pieces of information yes
they give it the texture and subjective
properties yes the we're so fond of in
the stimuli that comes in from the
exterior and yeah from our throw the
entirety of our path of life yeah until
yeah there's no mind that's exactly
yours receiving the exact same stimuli
and also if you think you ask yourself
why is it that the sound of ah subject
they feels very different from say that
experience of the color red you know
it's not anything to do with the outside
world it's actually represented in the
brain and very similar ways electrical
firings of neurons
that you couldn't it's hard to tell the
difference between an and the microscope
the reason one feels like a sound and
one feels like the visual experience
just has to do with its relation with
other pieces of information when it's in
your brain and you can have all that
experience even when you're not looking
you're hearing the world at all when
you're sleeping and dreaming right yeah
it still feels the same so there is
currently a an amount of math constants
equations that we have and then
interestingly enough you taught me that
there is potential for certain ones to
drop off as we figure out the more
proper ways to describe things but then
there's also undiscovered ones that
we're figuring out to better understand
the code of everything yeah so it's
important to be humble here right
although we have made huge progress with
science and with physics there are still
a lot of things we don't understand we
don't have that t-shirt yet with
equations everything for example we have
if you make a t-shirt with Einstein's
theory of gravity and you can make
another which describes all big things
really excellently and you can make
another t-shirt with the equations of
quantum mechanics which describe the
subatomic world really great but those
two teachers don't get along there is
another t-shirt that nobody has figured
out exactly what should be on it yet -
maybe a string theory maybe something
else and so some humility is in order
but it's quite striking how much
progress we've made you know 400 years
ago yes
like when Galileo famously said that our
universe is a grand book written in the
language of mathematics yes the almost
the only thing you could do with math
then it was predictive physics of motion
yes if Galileo could predict that if you
throw a hazelnut and a grape but they
would both move in the shape called the
parabola y equals x squared simple math
shape right but Galileo would have no
idea why the grape was green and the
hazelnut was brown while the grape was
soft and the hazelnut was hard then
Maxwell came with other equations for
light and stuff that explained colors
and then we got quantum mechanics which
explained why some things are hard and
others are soft and if you look now
we've actually gradually managed to
describe almost
we've gone from describing almost
nothing except motion with math to
describe almost everything with method
what mainly remains are some issues
about what's happening inside of black
holes will happen yes very very long ago
and around the time we were BIGBANG
Altimas future of our universe and most
flagrantly what's actually happening in
our heads yeah the science of
intelligence taking off quite a bit with
AI and but we certainly have a long way
to go and the most spectacular failure
if it field so far is our ability to
just to write down an actual scientific
theory of consciousness why is it that
we have these subjective experiences of
colors and sounds and so on rather than
just feel like zombies we go through the
motions but it doesn't feel like
anything to be us I'm I think some
people dismiss this is just silly
pointless philosophy I see it
differently I feel that we are just
being lame and making excuses for not
actually solving this science problem I
think both consciousness and
intelligence or all of our information
processing and and and so I don't think
it matter is ultimately whether the
information is processed by carbon atoms
inside of neurons inside of brains or by
silicon atoms in our technology but I
and what I do think matters is well
there is some kind so many other
equations which tell you which kinds of
information processing are conscious and
which aren't and we just haven't
discovered them and we should yes
absolutely
so let's touch on this potential of of
code because I'm quite interested in
your and your thoughts about this
there's big big conversations happening
about this about this role of of a god
or of what all that is is potentially
and of a simulation there's all of these
types of conversations going on what is
kind of your perspective on what is a
power that
is greater than humans that transcends
what we are that could potentially
govern this existence of this
mathematical universe are you talking
about the extent to which maybe we are a
part of something grander than us or are
you talking about kind of what makes the
unit our universe shake first yeah
well maybe a little bit of both yeah
yeah I mean our universe itself seemed
to be set up so that it keep ticking
along regardless of whether we are in it
know or not I don't think the Andromeda
galaxy would stop existing if all people
disappeared
I don't think Jim gromek galaxy was
called rotating etc so universe is like
a clockwork and in that sense if we
still have big questions that I wear it
all to hell ultimately came into being
and what's ultimately gonna happen to it
but it does seem to obey these these
mechanical laws to me know what's most
exciting about our universe and also
philosophically and emotionally and
spiritually most empowering and
interesting about it is that through us
a universe has actually become aware of
itself itself yeah for the first part of
the 13.8 billion years since our Big
Bang there was no one home our universe
is doing all this cool stuff especially
no one home well in the earliest moments
right after a Big Bang when it was just
a plasma expanding plasma blob you know
much harder than the core of the Sun I'm
pretty sure there was no consciousness
in there the life could be around as
early as just a couple billion years ago
Oh in other way sure earlier than that
yes it's quite possible but but very
early on and I think it's very likely
that it was just their way to in this
hospitable for any kind of consciousness
and then gradually it went from being
very simple and boring to being grabbed
more and more complex and the first
self-aware entities appeared yeah that's
in a sense of universe waking up and
becoming aware of itself right we know
what happened here on this planet maybe
it's happened elsewhere
maybe not yet we can come back to that
towards complexity mm-hmm yes in any
case I think that's the most important
thing that's happened so far because if
you look at all these laws of physics
they don't say anything about beauty
meaning or purpose mm-hmm yeah the
beauty meaning and purpose are all
things that you know which old only
exist when there is experience because
those are are in some sense experiences
right you can only have suffering or joy
or pleasure which are experiences when
there is experience right so if we go
extinct and all life somehow and our
universe goes extinct get the story by a
deaf bubble or some dumb technological
mishap we build our you know if we go
back to being meaningless and before I
woke up it was all so meaningless in
this sense this very literal sense there
was no meaning because meaning is it
kind of something you experience so this
is I think the most beautiful thing
that's happened so far this blob this
this universe you actually got so
complex that it woke up and well yeah
and what we one of the most striking
things I think we've learned through
science is it not only has the universe
woken up now but it has the potential to
wake up much more yes and as yet you
know yes I was taking a little power nap
before this interview and when I first
woke up I just woke up like a little bit
and then became more and more conscious
right you went through this same
procedure this morning
I feel like universe is like that - yes
we are having very interesting
experiences we humans but it's clear you
know which can wake up more you look
around on the telescope yes and it's
clear that the vast majority of space
it's not as alive as it could be some
people who listen to this maybe think we
live in are convinced we live in a Star
Trek kind of cosmos where there is all
of those cool things going on all over
the place and they're just hiding from
us
there's not any really cyclic evidence
for it yet you know maybe there is other
life really really far away the zoo
hypothesis it's an interesting ones yeah
but I think it's much more likely that
our universe has much more potential in
the future and I think one of the most
inspiring things for me personally to
think about is you know what can I do to
help our universe wake up more MORE
yes imagine from if it turned out that
you know we discovered that the only
life on all of Earth you know was in
Rhode Island or you know there was
nothing outside a rhode island no plants
no animals or nothing we might even feel
then that we have a moral responsibility
help life spread to help the rest of the
planet so it can wake up more so that
could be more joy or joy yeah
interesting and and and we reinforce all
across all different styles of
experience exactly yeah the opposite
thing we could do is more ideas more
creativity yes yeah exactly and the
opposite thing we could do is set off
some gigantic hydrogen bomb explosions
and kill that all life in Rhode Island
to that we feel like you kind of bad
idea which is a lot of what you do with
existential risk mitigation but but if
yeah but if that's bad then clearly the
opposite is a good thing to help life
spread right yes and if you look at into
the cosmos that's exactly what it is
except much more extreme than going from
Rhode Island to earth going from Earth
to help life spread throughout our Milky
Way galaxy and the hundreds of billions
of other galaxies it's a good analogy
would be a dream would be dramatically
more positive I think then yes it's just
going from Rhode Island to earth yes and
I think most people lose sight of just
how much opportunity there is for the
future
you know politicians are so focused on
the next election cycle and yes people
are worried about listen that the thing
that's gonna happen next week we forget
to like look up and the big history
perspective the collective
civilizational perspective how we got
here how grateful we are forgetting here
yeah and where we're going in the next
steps it will be exciting to have more
scientists and engineers in Congress
that will be a huge leap inbound for for
society although it's going in the
opposite direction you know there are
less scientists in Congress now than
they used to be well it's potential that
the scientists and engineers want to do
it on the entrepreneurial side of things
make the impact as entrepreneurs which
we've seen more and more entrepreneurs
making more impact than government can
which is very interesting to keep an eye
on and to inspire young kids to to
pursue ok can I I want to power around a
couple physics things before we move on
because otherwise we won't get the super
intelligence there's so much to cover in
the super intelligence and a GI and and
and geopolitics ethics around stuff like
that so um quick power around stuff what
is going on on the other side what of a
black hole on the other side of a
singularity it seems to be potential
that it's the birth of another Big Bang
it has a were do you and your answer we
don't know we don't know yes yes ok
there are so black holes what is a black
hole a black hole is just a region of
space where gravity is so strong that
nothing can come out of there right not
even light the boundary of the black
hole is called the event horizon and the
history of black holes is a great study
in humility because we kept discovering
over and over again that we were all
wrong about them first when Einstein
wrote down his equations of gravity this
guy called Schwarzschild discovered the
black hole solution and then from
decades and decades people thought that
actually the event horizon itself was
some kind of singularity was something
what's really weird with space then it
turned out that was just this math error
people had made and there's nothing
special that happens if you fall through
the event horizon except that you if
you're keeping track you have a sinking
feeling which if you're never coming
back yeah it's like the event horizon of
a black hole is like if you're swimming
in the Niagara River upstream from the
waterfall
there's one particular line through the
river way where the water
accelerates the Gopher faster than you
can swim you're not gonna die there you
just gonna have that whole [ __ ] moment
experience yeah and and then people
thought well you know you're gonna only
die when you come into the middle of a
black hole where there is this thing
called the singularity either a point or
a ring depending on whether it's
spinning then it turned out actually
there is another thing called the inner
horizon where you might actually die
earlier by hitting things that come at
you at the speed of light and then very
recently there's the firewall hypothesis
saying actually maybe you do die after
all that event horizon yeah and the
short answer as to what the truth is is
we really don't know we're studying and
it's a key in understanding the theory
of everything yeah because it turns out
that they're really rigorously answering
these questions it's not enough to just
work with Einstein's theory gravity also
have to throw in quantum mechanics into
that and those are the two theories we
mentioned earlier don't get along so you
don't ultimately know so the way I see
it is actually as an opportunity if we
can figure out what's going on with
black holes and maybe even get some
clues by looking at them then that can
actually maybe be the master key that
can help us unlock some of the deepest
mysteries of quantum gravity yes
yeah the unified theory of physics yes
and that's that's again that's
understanding the code and this is a
reoccurring theme okay another quick
power round question you've talked a lot
about multiverses and I want to do just
a specific understanding of the
multiverse because there's enough
conversations of you talking about them
online um the the multiple the
many-worlds interpretation of the
multiverse that there are multiple tons
of different max tegmark just breaking
out there are intersections of the
things that you do in everyday life did
you take the transit this way or that
way did you write the book or not did
you do that salad or burger etc that the
mamantov
of doppelgangers of you happening it's
so kind of a very spiritual thing to tad
to potentially tap into as well which
again we don't there's many different
ways to potentially do this through
meditation or through psychedelics tons
of different ways to explore this sort
of understanding of the the multiverses
poking and prodding at this you have a
you know you have a breakdown which you
know which will also link to so people
can take a look at well several links on
the bio for people to explore tell us
about the the many-worlds interpretation
of the multiverses okay well before
we're talking about parallel universes
let's just talk a little bit about what
we mean by our universe yes I brought it
here just so we can orient ourselves yes
when we say our observable universe or
just our universe for short we don't
mean all of space we mean this the
region of space from which light has a
time to reach us during the 13.8 billion
light years since our Big Bang meaning
there is plenty more outside of this
that we have yet to have the light comes
you know probably we haven't seen it yet
but every time we wait one more minute
light reaches us from another light
minute away and more stuff comes into
view
we've never suddenly had come into view
a sign saying space ends here you know
my little universe is constantly opening
up yeah it is it is so what we need
first of all is a hefty dose of humility
because we humans have again and again
made this mistake of thinking that
everything we knew about was everything
that existed just the discoverer that
that was just a small part of a much
grander structure right a planet a solar
system a galaxy yes our universe is that
we were the center and then we weren't
the sudden we were in just the storm and
we have a long track record on hubris
you sounded so humility is all good yes
now how much is there actually well
pretty much all of my physics colleagues
think that space is a lot bigger than
the this
and again every minute we wait we see in
fact more the most popular theory we
have what made our you our space in the
first place this made it so big called
inflation actually predicts in the
simplest version of the space goes on
forever forever and if that's true then
you can fit infinitely many other
universes regions into this where there
were lots of them big galaxies and
ultimately yeah
if you roll the dice and things started
randomly copies of us having all sorts
of very into this conversation this is
what I call the level 1 multiverse and
if it sounds weird it's only the
simplest four levels and I want to make
sure this is explained so max is saying
we are at the very center of this yeah
not because there's anything magical but
this edge it's just that if you're ever
walking in the fog and the visibility is
a hundred meters you'll feel that you're
in the center of your own little fog
sphere yes and that the extension of the
universe goes in all the directions in
infinite amount from here and that the
reason why there is this red ring around
the center is because this is where are
the disk of our galaxy yeah this is just
the photo of the edges of the part of
space that we can see taken with
microwave cameras on this necessarily W
map that's taking baby pictures of by
looking at the light that's been
traveling for 30-40 a billion years to
us seeing that when a universe was
thought was four hundred thousand years
old and it was we brought in twenty pens
as you said to forty cents per American
20 cents per American to make these
tremendous discoveries so next time you
think about the money that's being
allocated towards science give those big
thumbs up - yeah I've never met anyone
who would forfeit one bite of a burger
for these deep secrets about the cosmos
now we don't know for sure if space goes
on forever it might just be really
really big in which case there's a point
I know my parallel universes but the
inflation predicts typically that it
goes on forever
the simplest space we all were taught in
school and I
Euclid's space also goes on forever it
gets more even more interesting with
this inflation theory because it turns
out it makes almost like the fractal
space where whether these boundaries
where inflation never stops and these
everything within an expanding boundary
is caught there's a level of one
multiverse and then there are many of
them in level two multiverse and this is
such a violent process that the
different parts of space that are made
can actually if physics if space can be
in many different states kind of like
water can be in different states you
know ice steam
liquid you know with different
properties if space can't be like that
to which string theory suggest an
inflation is gonna make all these
different kinds of space that's level
two multiverse so there might be
somewhere far far away where people
learn in school that actually prepare
the periodic table has only five kinds
of atoms or a hundred and eighty kinds
of atoms and so on so here in our
universe the physics would be taught the
same across the planets but the history
is taught differently of how the
civilization evolved but in an
alternative part of a the next level of
a different place in the multiverse that
physics could in fact be different right
because not not because physics is truly
different it still may be on ruled by
string theory but a lot of things that
we thought were fundamental weren't it's
like if you're a fish and you've spent
your whole life in the ocean you might
think it was a law of physics the waters
always a liquid just because you've
never seen an iceberg
and you would learn that water has this
kind of viscosity and this kind of Sound
speed
which is not true if if you're inside of
an iceberg or a steam cloud and then the
third-level just that just adds more
humility we've discovered that basically
it's super hard to have any theory of
physics that just makes the stuff that
we can actually see
and observe and nothing more I gave you
two examples the quantum physics the
theory of they're very small has a same
property we've discovered that when we
look really closely at the electrons and
these other elementary particles that
make up us they can be in multiple
places at once but we are made of them
so that means we should be able to be in
many places at once and this guy you
Evert he worked that out and fifties and
showed that the quantum mechanics is
just true with no ifs and buts there's
this morning the Schrodinger equation
and that's it
then if as you were saying earlier as as
if our life kind of works out there are
many times when we make a decision snap
decision you know should we ask this
person on a date or not where it might
come down to just whether one neuron
fired or not in the beginning triggering
a whole cascade of events could end up
with you living in this city you know
they married to this person with
children or living somewhere completely
different doing something different yeah
and now that neuron firing might in turn
have been determined just by the
position of one little atom in your
brain so if that Adam was in two places
at once eventually you're living in two
different cities and so this kind of
branching and amplification of weirdness
from the micro world where a little atom
is in two places at once into the macro
world is what leads to this and so
called many-worlds interpretation of the
level three multiverse if that's
actually the way things are
yeah then every time you get a parking
ticket you can chill out and take solace
in the fact that there was probably
apparently universe you know what you
didn't kind of takes the pressure off a
little and it also at times feels as
though the potentially the Allens that
could have went and traveled Europe or
Asia for a little bit or the allen that
would have stayed in the same town of
Sioux Falls South Dakota instead of
going to San Francisco that I'm feeling
all of those Allen's at the same time
which is very strange there's there's a
lot - there's a lot too
talk they're still level 4 and went out
but I want to make sure we actually get
to you're doing 3d galaxy mapping as
well which is super exciting you're
working with all these different diverse
ly intelligent grad students and that's
been that's extremely fulfilling to see
and help mentor them and learn from them
and that's also really important work
that that you're doing I want to make
sure we get to super intelligence
there's you know there's a lot to talk
about regarding super intelligence okay
so somehow life evolved on earth
civilization managed to get the basic
water food electricity education
healthcare shelter to be able to birth
now seven point seven billion of us that
are alive now and a hundred billion
lived and died before them to make this
world so now we are children when you
were growing up didn't have the dull
these this law of accelerating returns
so not so much me growing up had a
little bit of accelerating returns now
now the kids born today have a lot of
accelerating returns in terms of the
exponential technology is associated
with computing of mapping the genomes of
of a mapping the brain of understanding
all of creating super intelligence so we
are kind of at an exponential importance
right now it's it has been accelerating
for a very long time but time scale on
which things double the technology
doubles in power is actually shortening
so it's in some sense growing even a bit
faster than exponentially in some areas
yeah yeah if you think about how long
did it take to double world GDP you know
from a thousand years ago it took a long
time or to double the world's population
now it takes much less time to double
the population yep yep or double the
total economy or double the executive
computers computering you have
population okay so this is actually
really important your you've done a
tremendous amount of work in this field
you're one of my mentors and so many
others mentors in this field with future
of life Institute what happened at a
sillim are two years ago or with the
twenty
three principles associated with
artificial intelligence safety security
figuring things out here and we've had
some of them on our show as well and
it's been super enlightening learning
from what's being done there talk to us
about because your future of life
Institute is is is taking this on you
know there's there's a lot there was a
you know autonomous weapons org is very
interesting where you're literally
showcasing a a really bad scenario that
could potentially evolve if the
geopolitics get out of hand and people
want to hurt each other for power or
greed or corruption and we need to slow
down and figure out the best way to move
forward another way that you're doing
this through all the grants that you're
that you're helping coordinate the
brilliant people that are working in the
field with people that want to fund
those grants so yeah tell us about this
because this is something that is so
pressing and beautiful thing working on
so what kind of runs like your way the
thread through our conversations so far
it and through my whole career is as you
know I've always been obsessed with big
questions and the bigger the questions
the more obsessed I've been with them
you know amen what's going on with
ultimate nature reality and so on and
the two biggest mysteries and science
the way I saw it when I lay in my
hammock as a teenager between two apple
trees was I the mystery universe out
there what I spent the first 25 years of
my career on and then our universe in
here telogen consciousness mine which
I'm work I've been working on in recent
years at MIT and in the very big picture
then what's happen is our universe is
woken up become aware of itself and some
of this these self-aware parts of our
universe namely us have become would
have managed to figure out so much now
about how it works through science they
were beginning to get better and better
building technology that actually act
back on our universe hey earth looks
very different now
at least the Boston area does from
you know million years ago because of
what we can do with our technology we
talked earlier about how we've even
discovered now that we actually have the
potential to do great things that help
life spread throughout University will
help a universe wake up much much more
we also of course have the potential to
do the opposite we're on the cusp of
technology that could just just
eliminate life completely and make your
universe permanently go back to sleep
so which so in some sense I feel that
after 13.8 billion years our universe
has reached this interesting fork in the
road we can take the life route or the
death route and I think there's no more
exciting question to work on to try to
make sure we make the right choice in
this fork and the way I think about it
is not I'm quite optimistic that we can
create a really inspiring future with
technology but that's gonna require
winning what I call the wisdom race the
race between the growing power of the
technology exponentially growing power
of the technology with the wisdom with
what you manage this tech yeah because
some people these days I find take
technology to be their new religion
basically worship it and say technology
is good and technology is morally good
the more technology we have the better
automatically and but it's important to
remember that technology is not actually
morally good and nor is it morally evil
technology is just a tool an amplifier
of your power to do good or evil yeah
and that means that the more powerful
attack becomes right the more important
it is to think about how you steer it
what you do with it right yes sometimes
people ask me about powerful tech like
AI and ask me if I are you for it or
against it then I always ask them what
about fire before fire or against fire
and that shows how ridiculous it is fire
isn't evil or good but it you know I'm
all for using it to keep this house warm
in the winter and I'm all against using
it to burn down our neighbor's house
so how can we actually win this wisdom
race then and make sure that we develop
our wisdom for technology management
fast enough that we do with good things
we'll attack the big and thing we learn
by looking at history is that we've all
in the past always used this strategy of
learning from mistakes first we invented
fire screwed up a bunch of times
then we invented the fire extinguisher
yep first we invented the car screwed up
a lot of times lot of people died then
we invented the seatbelt the airbag the
traffic lights and laws against driving
too fast laws against driving when
you're drunk as a skunk and stuff like
this so the wisdom I was always reactive
there's no room for reactive wisdom well
if there was with fire and so on yes
there were a lot of tragedies but I
think more like we more or less ended up
in a situation today where fire is much
more positive than negative in its
impact except for climate change but
there's a catch here because technology
is getting exponentially more and more
powerful
all right and at some point it crosses
the threshold of power we're learning
from mistakes actually goes from being
good strategy to being a really really
bad strategy and I feel we've already
crossed that threshold with nuclear
weapons and we've on the verge of
crossing the threshold with synthetic
biology which can be used fantastically
to improve our health or to create
engineer and pandemics and we're totally
gonna cross that threshold with
artificial intelligence if we succeed in
building artificial general intelligence
that can outsmart us you know in all
ways so which means that now is the time
to shift mindsets in this with wisdom
race away from just saying we're gonna
keep learning from mistakes to instead
being proactive and think see what can
go wrong to make sure we get it right
and it this might sound kind of obvious
to you since I see you're nodding but
it's funny because people sent them to
tell me
that's Luddite scare mongering
it's foresight that's having foresight
in figuring out how to work together
across the countries of the world in the
scientists of the world the ethicists of
the world this is extremely important
you know and nerdy MIT people like me we
call it safety engineering yes like how
come math you know when NASA was about
to launch the moon mission the Apollo
moon missions they systematically
thought through everything that can go
wrong when you put people on top of
explosive fuel tanks and launch them
took place where no one could help but
I'm right
was that Luddite scaremongering no that
was of course exactly the safety
engineering a safe let ensured the
success of a mission and this is exactly
what we're trying to do with the future
life Institute also yes thank you very
carefully in particularly with nuclear
weapons in AI what could go wrong to
make sure that it goes right and we get
that really awesome future some people
say well let's just stop technology you
know and think things over for a while
even if that were even if you think that
we're a good idea you know it's
obviously not gonna happen I'm a very
pragmatic person I'm interested in
solutions that can actually work if you
want to win a race there's two
strategies you can try to slow down the
competition in this case technology it's
just not feasible and crap and I'm not
two minutes it's even desirable or you
can try to run faster yourself so we're
doing the second strategy with the
future life Institute doing everything
we can to accelerate the developing
mentalist wisdom and get one more people
researching and thinking hard about how
to develop his wisdom yes just there are
technology in good ways and now let's
talk about the the direction because
this is so important okay quick on the
weighted direction I want to mention
this cuz it's so super important what
you what you've taught me the future of
life award happens yearly right now and
I'm very excited to see where this
continue is going so you taught me in
2017 about Vasili arkhipov and then you
Tommy in 2008
about stanislav petrov and these two in
1962 in the 1983 prevented during the
Cold War what could have cascaded into
mutually assured destruction of
civilization and the fact that they
helped prevent that from happening is
the exact reason why they received the
award and that the fact that
civilization knows Justin Bieber and Kim
Kardashian but doesn't know these two
humans is a major problem they need to
be in the history books they need to be
the ones that we amplify and put up on
major pedestals for everyone to know
that we are just such a soft gentle
species here on the planet that could go
and yeah yeah absolutely absolutely the
fact that there more people have heard
of Kim Kardashian and Justin Bieber bear
them Stanislav Petrov and Vasili
arkhipov is really very telling because
you could argue that there is no human
who's done a more positive contribution
for humanity than then resilient
appalled name your favorite politician
our and the past favourite thinker
yeah we've maybe been a bummer if they
weren't there but if it was silly
arkhipov hadn't said no yeah that time
on its own when this his submarine
captain wanted to launch a nuclear
torpedo at the American Navy during the
Cuban Missile Crisis we would not be
having this conversation and none of
those other people you thought about
would be relevant at all right same with
Petrov's ability to see that the ICBMs
the mistake in a rating system it's
sensing quite possibly yeah so I think
you know if if as civilization keeps
being very sloppy for a long time even
though they they realized that how many
nuclear war would be a bad idea it it's
know it because they're not aware of all
these close calls right the sloppiness
is due to ignorance and you're
highlighting these close calls for more
wisdom and aware
around these we learn more about the
heroes during the American Revolutionary
War in our school classes than about
these guys in fact they're never
mentioned arkhipov yeah yeah in fact my
kids went through the entire
Massachusetts public school system and
never even heard of learned anything
about nuclear weapons at all period Oh
what never got there never got to it in
history class or in science class and
I've been asking my uber drivers
recently just for kicks is sort of
unscientific poll how many nuclear
weapons they think that there are in the
world yes the first guy said three the
second guy said seven third one said six
the answer is fourteen thousand yeah so
but you can't blame them if they know we
don't teach this this is an example of
the kind of thing one thing we try to do
with future life is do just educate
people a bit better
yeah because most people when they find
out about this think oh my goodness I
don't want some doofus is being playing
playing Russian roulette with our
civilization like this US and Russia
have almost started nuclear war against
each other by accident so so many times
yeah and if we can't even and and yet
now the US government has decided to
spend over 1 trillion dollars 1 million
million dollars on getting rid of almost
no one nuclear submarines and missiles
and replacing in by new ones so you know
that's we there's that's there's gonna
be a bit lower than 1,000 dollars out of
your pocket and out of everybody else's
pocket more than 3,000 bucks per
American on something which is just
gonna make us less safe and I bet you
could think of something you'd rather do
with those 3,000 bucks if you had a
choice right well if we could get China
the Middle East Russia the US Africa
Europe everyone in South America to just
dose up on the love towards each other
then we could prevent spending $3,000 on
absolutely useless no it's worse than
useless if we just destruct if you took
this trillion dollars and and just go
one hundred dollar bills for it and then
set it on fire and nice fourth of July
bonfire that would be better it it would
cause a little bit of global warming but
at least it wouldn't affect that we
would have a nuclear war telling most
people on earth and spending it on this
is actually in that negative yes we
could totally scale back to having just
1000 hydrogen bombs if you make a list
of the 1,000 largest Russian cities and
just threaten to take those out if they
mess with us that's plenty too turnt
enough we don't need 7,000 it's same for
the Russians they also have 7,000 I
looked at a list of the US cities ranked
by size by the time you get down to the
mid 900 you get to Woburn Massachusetts
the next time over only Taiwan over here
most people watching this have never
heard of Auburn most never live in
Metropolis is around there Russians
don't have to threaten the nuke you burn
you first feel deterred right so we
could have closer to just a couple dozen
in steady yeah even if we went down from
7,000 to just 500 it would be much much
safer much less things that could go
wrong much and we're not doing it so
this is why we we have started giving
these awards out because we want to
celebrate the positive stories there
that there are people like that we
should be so grateful for and I yes
think we should have a norm as society
that whenever someone does something
really selfless it doesn't further their
own career at all now none of those guys
got promotions for this day yeah and
they should know that they will be
appreciated by future generations yes
and if they're dead when it comes out
gets the classified well then future
generations will show their appreciation
to their children yeah we should think
what we did in this case by giving them
40,000 bucks each because yeah octopops
daughter Yelena is living in Moscow and
very modest means and same thing for
style of Petrov's kids yes
and this is a way to to help the world
understand better about what happened
and who our heroes really
should be and I would like to just make
give a shout out if anyone watching this
if you know of some other unsung hero
that should be some email that person to
take mark at mit.edu will investigate
them a bit and maybe they can get yes
2019 future life award exactly so let's
talk about the direction of what's going
on so you were working with so many
different global leaders on the subject
of figuring out where an artificial
general intelligence that both the in
where the direction should go and this
has a lot to do with the the geopolitics
of these things and also the programming
of these things there seems to be a I
want to talk about it from a kind of a
high level like over the next couple of
decades if not a hundred or more years
that what seems to be the preferred
scenario with an artificial general
intelligence as a merge scenario where
we slowly over time become more digital
and less biological over generations and
that that tell us about about this so
what's gonna happen to the future of
life if we don't screw up and somehow
why powered by some doing something dumb
and you with nuclear weapons and maybe
with my building AI that gets out of
control
what what's in store for us well
ultimately I don't think we should ask
what will happen we should ask what do
we want to happen because we're the ones
building this tech right and it's
fascinating how different visions people
different people have in terms of what
they're most excited about some people
want to basically keep things the way it
is now but just cure cancer I eliminate
poverty solve the climate challenges and
basically today's our world but better
others want to try something more
radical
so upgrade our bodies a bit more with
technology maybe so we could live much
longer maybe even become a bit more like
cyborg you know you like must is working
on your lane or a link with his team
there's a lot of things you can imagine
trying to do and and then some want to
go the ultimate jump starting with this
assumption that intelligence and
consciousness are all about information
processing and ask how can you take this
information processing and liberate it
from our biological body and into some
other platform where it can essentially
be immortal and make copies of itself
that's the idea of uploading yep if you
can do that then even what it would feel
like to be alive could ultimately be
very different from how it feels to us
because our minds right are very very
shaped by their evolutionary past that's
why we are so into eating and drinking
and not falling off cliffs and the kind
of things which in dating the kind of
because ultimately all the for
information your minds are for optim-r
brains we only got our genes of all
brains just to help make copies of them
sounds right
that's why we have some of these alpha
male characteristics which are getting
or getting our civilization into a lot
of trouble if you have a more artificial
it's some if you go to artificial
consciousness the mind space of what's
possible is much bigger mm-hmm doesn't
have to be like that at all there it's
not limited to the physical world
yeah and for example we have a very
strong fear of death because we know
that if we die all the information gets
deleted in our brains and there is a
down before we if we yeah so if we move
of course you can write a book and share
some information you can you can often
do manage to get their children to learn
and the doctor more
best values and as a teacher I find it
very satisfying if I can also share some
ideas I'm excited with others so they
can live on but most of the information
still gets deleted which is kind of a
bummer whereas if your that's right if
you're an upload and you're in a sari
and you're in a plane that's about to
crash instead of saying oh crud I'm
gonna die
you'd be like oh what a bummer I'm gonna
lose two hours of my life because I
didn't back myself up since two hours
ago it's less of a big deal and people
can dig through that archive of your
mind and learn from you yeah and you can
just restart from where you were two
hours ago and also in a new flash
vehicle or in a new robotic fear yeah
and and the reason why we are so
egoistic and sometimes unnecessarily
competitive also has a lot to do with
the fact that our information is stuck
in our minds right if we could just
freely copy information from our friends
right if you go and understand the lot
of time and learn how to speak Japanese
and I can just me let me copy that
Japanese module and I'll let you copy my
Swedish module you know and we can share
experiences and other insights and so on
then even then our life starts to become
more about experiences and the
individuality starts to go away a little
bit we become almost like a hive mind in
some sense so it's fascinating to think
about if we end up going that route what
kinds of minds could actually exist them
and what kind of mind you would actually
want to be in the future yes that's
right and you're doing a lot of
conversations with global leaders on
this subject and it's very difficult to
handle this geopolitically there is a
there's a ton of variables that are
going on well I die would be a bit more
cynical about and radical about this
it's not difficult at all to make the
world much much better it's just that we
have our monkey brains and
and most political leaders very clueless
about technology and all and are also
really not thinking particularly big
they're just focused on with playing
some zero-sum game and winning the next
election I mean it's not like we don't
know how to eliminate hunger on earth
right we know we've had the technology
for that for a long long time why are we
not doing it it's because our monkey
politics basically yeah well it's not
like we know don't know how to eliminate
the threat of nuclear war of course we
know how to do it to it yeah you just
get Putin and Trump get together yeah
over over beer and they could yeah I
could make a deal and sort things out
they're the reasons these things aren't
happening or not because the five year
old couldn't figure out how to do it
it's because there are other forces that
sort of don't want it to happen
yeah that's why is it that we don't hear
it's a linear hunger it's same deal it's
because there are other powerful forces
that actually prefer the status quo and
would you say those powerful forces are
well you know we're pretty greedy
species everybody everybody's looking
out for their own little thing and often
these these motivations don't line up
very well with with what would be better
for everyone even though and this is the
opportunity it's not a zero-sum game
we're playing right so it there would be
a way pie always grow there would be a
way of just doing things running thing
doing things better on earth so that
everybody gets better off yes the rich
get richer the poor get richer there's
no more hunger there's no nuclear war
yes but we're not doing that because
well if I can get baguette super nerdy
we're stuck in really crappy Nash
equilibrium this economist John Nash
there's a beautiful film called A
Beautiful Mind about him
pointed out that if everybody is just
following their own you a stick interest
at any one time you often end up at a
situation where everybody's worse off
yeah whereas if if they could find a way
of collaborating with each other they
would all benefit it's a balance between
the self-interest and the collective
interest so what you want to do it
typically is set up a legal system or
other mechanisms that make people
collaborate more so that everybody gets
better off or off but we the world is
full of situations like the prisoner's
dilemma or the tragedy of the Commons
where this just doesn't happen and this
is this is a very very interesting thing
to think about if you want to make
society better
how can you enable this kind of you know
obviously neither of the Americans no
other Russians want the nuclear war for
example it would not very nice for
anyone a deep sense of compassion I
don't think one even knees have so much
this fashion if you think about like why
don't we have the why don't people
killed each other every time they have a
quarrel about something well because a
lot of people did that during the Stone
Age and then gradually the groups that
managed to come up with a good set of
norms where they really punish people
who were too violent were able to
succeed better as groups and out-compete
the other groups that just kept killing
each other so now I'm pretty much all
countries on earth right have laws they
lock people up when they're doing uncle
a buret Avance on it wasn't it's not
compassion necessarily it's just
collaboration and it's not a zero-sum
game when if people collaborate they can
all get better off the pie is gonna keep
the baseline fir for everyone is raised
up over time compassionately and
technologically and and just a lesser
self of selfishness and a more of a
collective and I mean it's fine to be
selfish the market economy is powered
very successfully by selfishness as long
as you have rules that sort of align
people it's selfish self-interest with
what's good for everyone and in the more
technology as you mentioned is the key
to all this
because before there was much in the way
of technology
life on Earth was really just a zero-sum
game the only way you can get more I was
taking from someone else like Sweden I'm
where where I was born and Denmark next
door we had all these stupid words
sometimes Sweden got a little bigger or
sometimes Denmark or a little bigger but
nobody on average nobody really got any
richer now that is growing and now we
haven't had any wars with Denmark or
anyone else for 200 years and both
Denmark and Sweden are dramatically
richer because technology has improved
in both countries yeah and today we will
a in particular we have the potential of
making everybody again dramatically
richer yes if we can control this
technology to not destroy us the Chinese
can get much richer the Americans get
much richer everybody else can get much
richer and healthier and healthier
wealthier and and so on we get the best
for everyone around yeah if we can
manage to collaborate and not just just
wipe out with this stuff yes yes ok max
you have this really beautiful imagery
will will have it right here where you
have the the the mountaintops and the
shores and the general idea is that the
rising tide of artificial intelligence
across different fields is rising up in
the fields that we already see being
automated the cash unless cashiers are
already here there's tons of these
examples where these are the fields that
are at the shoreline that are already
being autumn a and they're creeping up
and then the mountaintops are much
further away from automation yeah and so
what would be the piece of advice that
you could give parents and children to
be robot proof to be AI proof on the
mountaintops for as long as possible
so in short it was go into careers that
machine's suck at and are going to
continue to be bad at for a long time
they are tend to be two ears which
involve a lot of creativity
unpredictable elements you have the deal
with there are also a lot of jobs where
the customer actually prefers paying a
premium
for it to be a human that the liver is a
service those are all good
in contrast a career where you're
driving a vehicle you know bad idea a
career where you spend most of your time
just reading something off the computer
and typing something back into the
computer in a pretty structured way you
know I'm not gonna last long I also
think it's important to remember it's
not that there are some careers that are
all good and some that are all bad
almost whatever career you go into there
will be some aspects of it we're gonna
get all our which are on the verge of
automation so if you want if you excited
about medicine for example then don't
become the radiologist who spend all day
long staring at the MRI scans on the
computer and types in the diagnosis and
gets replaced by an AI in two years now
being a doctor that gets this AI
diagnosis and discusses the treatment
plan with the patient if you into law
you know don't be the paralegal who
spends endless hours reading through
massive troves of documents and gets
replaced by an AI in one year but be the
lawyer who gets the AI analysis and
argue the case in court right that way
you're working with the AI rather than
against it and whatever career you in
even if it feels like it has very little
to do with the AI you need to stay up to
speed on how AI is impacting it so you
can be the one who gets it to work for
you it makes you more competitive you
know rather than less yep and then the
other thing is you just have to let all
this idea that you or your kids are
gonna educate themselves for many years
and then have the same job of 40 years
those their days are over and they're
never coming back
so whatever career we're in we're gonna
have to keep adapting stay up to speed
about what say I doing and then as we
just talked about see how can you use
that to make yourself more productive
rather than letting that just replace
you last question what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
you know other than my wife you leave
okay I have my wife of course but I
think I think you did more philosophical
way I think it's it's really beautiful
to me this idea and that through us our
universe itself has become beautiful
because as we discussed earlier before
there was any consciousness our universe
wasn't beautiful it was like you played
four empty benches right nobody there to
see it and if we can get her act
together which is what I really hope and
what I would love to work with many of
you who are watching this to help ensure
that the but you know the life keeps
flourishing more and more and as we go
into the future
then our universe can wake up even more
and they can be even more beauty seen by
even more conscious beings and that
would be beautiful of such a good answer
max this has been such an honor
let's get more people working together
on future of life on so many of the
complex issues that you're helping
pioneer and so many others that you're
working with join will have all the
links in the bio for you to do so in the
directions max thank you so much for
joining us for coming on to the show you
is a pleasure really appreciate you so
much and as max s all the time dream big
dream big
get to your moonshot goals we always
talk about this as well on the close
thank you so much for watching we
greatly appreciate you give us your
thoughts in the comments below
execute your dreams into the world
manifest your destiny and everyone much
love and we will see you soon peace
that's it thank you that was fun thank
you thank you that look that look what
actually just like